I would emphasize the significance of vision.
It represents your aspiration,
your desired outcome, your goal and entirety,
the picture of the future that you desire.
Mission would be your purpose and the reason for your career pursuits.
However, that can only be flawed with your vision or by your vision.
Core values are your fundamental beliefs,
the principles that guide your behaviour,
your decision making, and who you eventually become.
So without that picture, all of this would not be able to contemplate.
So if I were to prioritize,
I'm going to take vision over,
emphasize vision over core values and mission statements.
If your vision is not up, if your vision is not clear,
if your vision is not big enough,
when the vestitudes of life come to play,
you'll get distracted.
The second level of alignment that a man must come into is your vision
that provides that level of alignment.
You want to do this. You naturally do this.
You enjoy doing this. But your vision tells you that, hey,
if you are going to be a sportsman,
you can't be having pizza and Coca Cola for dinner.
The reason people get overwhelmed
is because there's no clarity of thoughts.
Take a camera, for instance.
When the focus angle is not exact,
the picture is blurry. That's the way it is with life.
Every time there's tardness,
every time there's eagerness,
every time there's frustration,
sometimes even depression,
is a lack of creative vision.